ever since the inception of the Nobel
Prize over century ago a home for the
Nobel legacy has been envisioned to
focus on the story's discoveries and
achievements connected to the Nobel
Prize a place for stories of courage
conviction and persistence stories which
prove that ideas can change the world
now the Nobel Prize will get its home in
the heart of Stockholm the combination
of you know Nobel a site on the water at
Stockholm I mean it's a very attractive
invitation for an architecture to look
at this is unique this is the most
amazing competition they've done for a
while in let's do everything the winner
of the international architectural
competition for the Nobel Center is the
renowned David Chipperfield Architects
in Berlin their sophisticated design
proposal was elegant and timeless with
an appealing lightness and openness
which was to the jurors liking totally
excited by this challenge I think
you know all projects are important but
this project has enormous meaning not
just for the city of Stockholm
international the Nobel Center will be a
unique public place for exhibitions
activities school programs events and
interdisciplinary meetings we can help
each other and we can also achieve the
achieved it principles the values that
gathered you know the humanity the
various activities around the Miguel
prize have have moved out in many
different directions and this is a way
to bring them all together enough and
what is a beautiful setting the middle
of Stockholm it can be spectacular on
its greatest night but also it can be
very useful and functional and working
for all the rest of the year a noble
center that inspires engages and
encourages curiosity a noble Center to
host future Nobel Prizes many Nobel
Prize winners are only too happy to
influence young people it's the best
legacy you can leave by encouraging
discovery and new thinking and by
addressing the major challenges of our
time in our future the Nobel Center will
continue the legacy of the Nobel Prize
basically the time to come up with this
which is amazing
one day you're invited to participate
it's quite amazing really an
architectural challenge doesn't become
doesn't come much better